last week the Tennessee legislature
passed its Bill Banning drag shows for
children actually it bans all sexual
performances in front of children the
bill uses the phrase adult Cabaret and
drag is not especially singled out or
even specifically mentioned
drag queens have felt personally
targeted simply because they happen to
be the only ones who want to perform
sexually for children the law forbids
anyone and everyone from engaging in
sexualized displays in the site of
minors we are all equally restricted in
that area now in Tennessee but the
difference is that the rest of us have
no desire to do such a thing we are
repulsed by the very thought of it many
drag queens apparently do have this
desire and so they complain that they're
being especially oppressed by this
prohibition
now the days since the Bill's passing
the media has published one sob story
after another telling us about the
horrible plight of Tennessee drag queens
who fear that they may never be able to
perform a striptease for elementary
schoolers ever again and that really
really uh is a tragic thing for them
Business Insider just published
interview with local drag queen Bella
dubal and this is the same man who as we
heard last week gave a speech at a
recent drag event threatening violence
and riots if the ban on child
sexualization is passed
um he uh you know insinuated that if
he's not able to
uh sexually perform in front of a child
then he might start smashing people with
bricks that's how important it is to him
that he's able to do this now that it is
passed um even though he was the one
threatening violence he now says that he
fears for his life here's The Insider
report an interview with Insider dubal
called the bill terrify and said she's
personally afraid for her own safety
notice the female pronouns by the way
that we're using for drag queens
who don't even say that they identify as
women
but are but are you know putting on a
character and so they're referring to
the character as if the character exists
in real life in the article
um it's like if there was a if there was
an interview with Joaquin Phoenix and
the interviewer referred to him as the
Joker in the article
the bill specifies that a second offense
would be considered a classy felony
which carries a jail sentence of up to
six years
quote I could go to prison for six years
for appearing in a public Pride Parade
the ball said I'm scared that if I'm
wearing gender non-conforming clothing
in Kroger and someone has their kids and
they clutch them tight and call the cops
I could get arrested just for presenting
that way uh in my daily life
quote there has never there's never once
been a child who has been sexually
assaulted or harmed at a drag show or a
pride performance if there had been it
would be a poster image for their
campaign we would see it everywhere
now of course
as we know these people lie about
everything all the time and he's lying
here the law would not result in him
getting carted away in handcuffs if he
cross-dressed at Kroger
as much as that thought might be
pleasing to some of us
um that's not what would actually happen
this law specifically Outlaws sexual
performances
so unless he's in the produce section
twerking on the avocados he probably
doesn't have much to worry about in that
regard as for the claim that no child
has ever been assaulted or harmed at a
drag show
what he means is that there's been
no video of a child being physically
molested by a drag queen on camera
during the performance
because anything outside of that
doesn't count as assault or harm
apparently according to him
which is an interesting claim coming
from a guy who would certainly insist
that grown adults are both assaulted and
harmed when someone say quote-unquote
misgenders them
words pronouns can be a form of assault
yet for a child there is by this man's
telling nothing he can say to them or do
in front of them that would count as
harmful
we see once again how the most fragile
adults who have ever who have ever
walked the face of the Earth okay the
people who collapse into tears and
scream genocide if you say words they
don't like these same adults seem to
have somehow an unshakable faith in the
ability of small children to endure and
process any image or idea or experience
the adult needs to be protected from
from pronouns that scare him the child
doesn't need to be protected from even
R-rated sex shows according to this guy
this is why these people see it they
want us to see it that way but it is of
course totally wrong
in fact there is video evidence of
children being harmed at drag shows
every single child who's ever attended
one has been harmed
they are all abuse victims this is
abusive inherently by its nature to
involve children in something like this
and the abusers are only becoming more
Brazen about it case in point
footage has gone viral this week of a
show called
Kaba Baba Rave now this is a as you
might pick up from the name a cabaret
rave
that is meant for babies
yes babies it is a touring show that
goes from place to place performing
sexual Cabaret for babies and toddlers
here's an article on the British website
called the mank advertising one of these
shows first from a few months ago
because this has been going on for a
while
quote a cabaret Rave sensory experience
especially for babies and toddlers is
coming to Manchester later this year and
tickets are now on sale our city region
may never be short of unique events and
interesting things to be getting up to
but kabba Baba Rave is gearing up to be
unlike anything else on offer for little
manx and their parents as it's bringing
the experience of a big London night out
to a popular social club uh this October
it's described as being a little slice
of Afternoon Delight that provides
show-stopping Cabaret interspersed with
baby sensory moments
and if that all wasn't captivating
enough as it is each session ends in a
rave Kappa Baba Rave is hosted by Lizzy
and Gemma two performers turned moms who
were constantly looking to be
entertained whilst holding a baby in one
hand and a pint in another
yes baby sensory moments is the
euphemism that they're using here
and if you're hearing about all this and
you're thinking to yourself well wait a
minute no way this we must be missing
something there's just no way that this
can be what it sounds like I refuse to
believe that something like this exists
a cabaret Rave for babies
well the footage of one of these events
should wake you up to the horrifying
reality it is very real
um and as you can see as you put the
images up on the screen there are
parents sitting around with their babies
and toddlers
watching as men in bondage gear swing
around on ropes
there's another man in a in a wearing a
thong and nothing else and doing a
handstand and spreading his legs doing
all of this for babies and toddlers
there are half naked adults adults
twerking
this is a full-on R-rated sex show
targeted at children three and under
that's what it is and it's as I said
been going on for a while Kaba Baba Rave
has been hosting sold out shows for
months at least without anyone objecting
or at least without the sorts of people
who would object finding out about it
now that we have found out about it the
groomers behind Kaba Baba Rave have
locked everything down they've gone into
hiding basically at least uh you know in
in cyberspace
um the website has been taken down the
Instagram Facebook page all that has
been turned to private and this happened
the moment that
these images of footage
emerged on social media and people like
normal people saw this they shut
everything down
the organizers put out this statement
just to let our followers know we've
turned out we've turned our profile to
private for a while we've been subject
to a pretty horrific trolling attack and
it just keeps coming as mothers with
young Toddlers and one of us heavily
pregnant this has become more stressed
than we're able to deal with right now
these trolls specifically have a problem
with drag artists and non-binary
performers performing for children which
is exceptionally sad as those of us who
have been uh who have been who those who
have been to our event will know how
much joy love and happiness our shows
bring
oh they are the victims of course they
think what a surprise
now
why is this happening I mean what is the
motivating motivation for the adults
involved
well there's a lot going on we can
assume that the performers are perverts
who get a sexual thrill out of exposing
themselves to children
the parents are sick twisted freaks who
signal their allegiance to the woke
religion by offering up their children
in this way uh making a sacrifice of
their children's innocence for some of
them it might also be as well more of a
selfish disregard
um I mean it's selfish regard across the
board but they're also they're also
parents who who personally want to
attend these kinds of performances and
they bring their kids along because they
don't really care what effect it will
have on the kids
and then for All the Above
there's also the overarching intention
to desensitize and confuse children to
induct them into the less sexual
pathologies and obsessions from a very
young age to groom them in other words
so there are varied motivations for all
these adults but one thing that they
have in common
is that they should all be sitting in a
prison cell right now and we will know
that we have restored some semblance of
sanity and dignity in our culture when
but not until we start seeing Law
Enforcement Officers swarming these
kinds of events handcuffing every adult
in the room and frog marching them out
of the building and into a prison cell
okay you could take the drag perverts in
their thongs and just throw them right
into jail we'll see how um sexually
expressive they want to be in that
environment
and then you take the kids away from the
parents and you throw the parents into
jail right alongside them
that's how we have to respond
because these perverts are not going to
stop on their own
they will only get more brazen
we have to stop them aggressively
by force by law
and that's why we need every Republican
presidential candidate in 2024 to
promise a federal ban on these child
drag shows okay kids in Tennessee are
protected now
but all children deserve the same
protection
we cannot be satisfied with a few
legislative victories in a few States
those are very good those are good
things that's a step but it's only a
step in the process and just as the ban
on child gender transitions must go
Federal
so must the law against this kind of
degeneracy
the other side they're only getting more
bold
more Brazen more extreme
we have to meet them with that same
energy
an absolute zero tolerance policy for
groomers that's the only way for
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign